h
اجرب طيب اشوف بس
انزل طيب السلام
عليكم معكم عمار فيصل بوازير 16 سنه من
داره فكر صفوه
ثانوي بس نزل شيار نزل ش
الار
ش
us
w
طيب السلام
عليكم اول شيء حاب اقول انه قصتي مع
الجيتار اول شيء تعلمت الجيتار كيف صف
خامس صف خامس سويت حفله عيد ميلادي وجاني
جيتار جيتار سبانش طبعا اللي انتم شايفينه
جيتار اكوستيك
ا بعدها صرت احاول اتعلم بعده بيوم يومين
ثلاثه ما صرت تعرف تتعلمه حطيته في
الدولاب لمده تقريبا سنتين وصرت اشوف
اخويا صار يعرف يزف فيها وبس وحبيت الشغله
وقلت له لو سمحت يعني علمني وزي كذا والله
يحفظه وعلمني
و بعد ما علمني قال لي انت تعلمت اغنيه
واحده راح تعرف تتعلم بها غاني ثانيه
قلتله كيف قاللي افتح اليوتيوب وتعلم بس
وزي ما انتم شايفين وكل اللي سويته طبعا
من اليوتيوب وطبعا اللي اعطاني الهديه
ابراهيم الغامدي شكرا
ابراهيم طيب ويعطيكم الف
عافيه